several White House staffers and members
of the Secret Service who work in close
proximity to the President on a daily
basis have now tested positive for covin
19 we know that Fox News also confirms
one of them as David just mentioned for
us is the vice president's press
secretary Katie Miller joining us to
break down at testing efforts at the
White House and across the nation is
director of Harvard's Global Health
Institute dr. Ashish Jha dr. Joe we
always love speaking to you thanks so
much for taking time again out of your
very busy weekend for us we appreciate
it
my pleasure thanks for having me on so
first question is about these White
House staffers and then we'll open up
the conversation to testing more
generally the White House says they're
now going to test everybody who comes
into close proximity with President
Trump to prevent higher probability of
him contacting the virus that sounds
great but tell us does that like is this
even a realistic goal in the sense that
you can test somebody once and know that
they're fine that day but then if
they're gonna just see the president the
day after are they going to be testing
White House staffers every single day
and is that what they would need to do
yeah so it just tells you how difficult
it is to maintain a completely safe
environment and obviously keeping the
president of the vice president safe are
of the highest priority and so I think
they probably do need to be doing daily
testing but even that isn't going to be
a hundred percent foolproof because we
know that you can have the virus and
test negative it's just not a perfect
test it's a pretty good test but it's
not perfect so I understand the strategy
they're using I think it's the right
strategy but it's a reminder that even
in the White House with daily testing of
all the staff it's not a hundred percent
in terms of making sure that no one
who's infected gets near the president
is there any way to get to a hundred
percent or you're saying that's just
take it off the table it's not something
that anyone could realistically do so
again the goal is I mean a hundred
percent I don't know how we get to but
you can get pretty close right and and
the way you do it is you limit the
number of contacts to the president you
do make sure you test all those people
you keep those people reasonably
quarantine so those people should not be
going out to restaurants and bars not
that bars are even open but you know
keep those people in relatively confined
spaces and I think you can protect the
president I'm not saying it's impossible
I'm just saying a hundred percent is
always hard but you can get pretty close
with lots and lots of testing so now
when we look at the rest of the United
States we're kind of split between
states that are staying shot states that
are reopening or trying to reopen their
economies you say you know there's these
widespread protests now against certain
businesses that are staying against
governments that are keeping businesses
closed excuse me but you say to those
folks don't hate the stay at home orders
hate the lack of testing that got us to
those policy solutions in the first
place right yep yeah so look even the
president just by his action what's
happening at the White House it's an
acknowledgement that testing is really
helpful it's not the only thing we need
but it's a really critical part of
keeping America safe and my take is if
that's the strategy the White House
using is using to keep that workplace
safe that's the strategy we all should
be using now again not everybody needs
to be tested every day but we do need a
lot more testing as a key part of
keeping people safe so that we can open
up safely and get our economy back and
make sure that people don't get infected
and die in large numbers we can do both
of those things keep people safe and
open the economy but testing is a really
fundamental part of that yeah a good
reminder they're good at a point that
maybe the White House on this is leading
by example so when the president talks
about testing not being a universal
necessity look at what the White House
staff is implementing to keep him safe I
want to get your final thoughts on this
terrible war news we're hearing now
where a number of children I don't want
to misstate what's happening so correct
me if I get this wrong but a number of
young children are getting these sort of
secondary inflammatory diseases
resulting from Cova 19 we know that one
five-year-old now is
died in New York tell us about what you
see in this sort of new developing piece
of the puzzle yeah so one of the one of
the bright spots of this terrible
pandemic and one of the sort of silver
linings has been that kids have
generally done very well they do get
infected they do spread the disease but
they generally themselves don't end up
getting very sick and it's very very
rare when kids die obviously any time a
child dies of anything including kovat
it's a tragedy what we are seeing is
that we're learning a lot about this
virus including that it sets off an
immune reaction that in kids can really
cause a lot of difficulty so again most
kids still end up getting through it
okay I don't want people to get
excessively worried but it is something
we're gonna have to watch carefully and
learn more about because obviously if it
leads to kids getting very safe that is
something we're gonna have to pay a lot
attention to it obviously would be a
very devastating game-changer you know
not just for Americans but for folks all
over the world dr. Joe we'd love to get
you back soon thanks for sharing your
expertise with us today thanks for
having me on